las vegas is at the top of a new list  right behind reno they're the top two  fast warming cities in the u.s according  to non-profit climate central the  temperature difference is color coded on  this map you can see las vegas toward  the southern state has seen a near six  degree rise in summer temperatures since  1970 while reno up here  a 10 percent increase experts say as we  get warmer air quality and heat related  illnesses will continue to worsen  now with unprecedented heat across the  u.s the biden administration is helping  americans better understand and plan for  extreme temperatures heat.gov is now  live it includes forecasts the cdc's  heat and health tracker and safety  information  jerry over to you in the weather center  thanks for